talk to the guys around this team i mean
you're talking about leadership i mean
williams is the guy that we point to
because of his energy brett anderson the
guy pitches like his hair's on fire and
he would love to secure a serious sweep
here this afternoon partner yeah like to
get some ground balls i mean
he's a loser his last time out that was
against the nationals at home five in
the third five hits three runs in a four
to one brewers loss in that game making
start number four against cincinnati
this year and the reds have runners at
the corners for joey votto with one man
out
vado
center field
bradley known for his range not his arm
tag at third fire in india slides in
safely sac fly rbi
navado's team leading 82nd ribby and the
reds lead it one to nothing sunny gray
on a sunny day in milwaukee wisconsin
he's only made 19 starts he's had three
different injuries a back problem a
groin problem and a rib cage strain so
sonny gray just getting back at it
i mean he's won his last three decisions
and that covers the last five
starts look at the run on that swing and
a miss strike three
that brings up amazeo garcia
throw down tag is there
long dead to rights india on the spot
and stevenson with the dynamite time
it's two strikes
on luis oreos
swing and a miss strike three
sonny gray has faced the minimum one
ball and two strikes on sonny gray
sonny gray rolls one up the middle gonna
be a tough play here jump throw by wong
and out at first wow gray is really fast
and almost beat that out and reds want
to take a look at this pretty good jump
throw by colton wong got as much on it
as he could
but it does look like he was just a
touch late that'll be overturned
don't agree with an infield hit sonny
gray who has only seen one man reach
beautiful pitch from gray as he paints
and strikes out peterson peterson
looking bad looking for the breaking
pitch right there thought maybe that
break
breaking pitch would come down low and
then break right down out of the strike
zone instead it was a fastball
now the pitcher brett anderson
strike three how does a hitter let alone
a picture hitting
prepare for a grazing 77
followed by 93 that does that there the
athletic training staff now comes out
and he's down on the ground stretching
his leg out
that's what put him on the injured list
but he's staying in the game he's got to
go back to the top of the order and
colton wong
[Applause]
routine
three scoreless in the books for
right-hander sonny gray i'm sure he'll
get a little treatment when he heads
into the deck out one-nothing cincinnati
brewers going after a sweep today of the
reds
a swing and a miss castiano has chased
one
anderson with a strikeout his second
that's how the fourth inning starts
tellez standing there bad on shoulder
waiting
grey's pitch
strike three called got him looking with
a fastball right at the top of the zone
he locks up teles
gray with his fifth strikeout today this
is the reigning player of the week in
the national league right here tyler
naquin who's riding a 14-game hit streak
a little tapper top play anderson
flips it out of his glove and it hits
naquin telez loses his glove flung up
into dakwood's hip that takes tolez's
glove off his hand
to help stretch the longest active hit
streak
and a major league baseball making a
career high 15 in a row
boy anderson does not look good here he
was not running after that ball well
tight hamstrings there that's it he's
out another
exit from brett anderson he just cannot
stay on the mountain right hip tightness
the brewers clubhouse said for brett
anderson hunter strickland is on
jonathan india has singled and scored
the game's only run
india rocket to right
home run
jonathan india gets that bullpen up
and his 17th homer of the season has the
reds ahead four to nothing this kid is
unbelievable nick castellanos leads it
off he'll face new pitcher prince pseudo
and hit by nick castellanos a line drive
to left
it slams off that recess wall his second
homer in as many days and a five nothing
reds edge
and the reds are in all their glory
today great pitching by sonny gray and
big time offense here bases loaded two
outs rowdy teles the batter
breaking ball pounded into the ground
novato two hops he's got it underhands
to gray at the bag
3-1 side retired and the brewers leave
them loaded rebs will go to the bullpen
for the first time here this afternoon
as they bring on right-hander tony
santiago he'll get luis
sends one deep into left center
and this is going to fly a home run for
luisa
that didn't take long to get to that
bullpen number 17 for urias
and the brewers are on the board here in
the seven one out and runners at first
and second
long a 3 30 hitter against lefties this
season back for the 1-1 ground ball
should be two barrero steps on the back
throws novato
inning over nice job by justin wilson as
he comes on and just flat shuts down the
brewer rally goes down to the last two
peterson
a little flare that's going to fall for
a base hit
well placed
jase peterson is on with a one-out
single
first hit of the day for jace he did
walk his last time up
jackie bradley jr with the runner on and
one out you got peterson's got center
caught of the fly barrero lunging tag
out of the basement baseline yes
[Applause]
great council is out he is upset the
reds bench is emptying to exchange hugs
because the game's over
craig council claims he's not out of the
baseline but the goal to the field
out of the baseline evading
the simultaneous catch and diving tag
try
from barrero
and a double play to end the game and
end the series with a 5-1 reds win